Yesterday, May 28th, we witnessed one of
the most heroic Christian victories
against Islam, the battle of Kovadanga
in Spain. Today in history, however, on
May 29th, 1453, we must witness one of
the most tragic defeats of all time. For
today is the day when the scimitar of
Islam finally conquered
Constantinople. So, let's discuss it.
Not least because of all of Islam's
conquest of Christian territory, this
was by far the most symbolically
significant. For not only was
Constantinople a living and direct
extension of the Roman Empire and
current capital of the Christian Roman
Empire, commonly known today as
Bzantium, but its cyclopian walls had
prevented Islam from entering Europe
through its eastern doorway for the pre
previous seven or eight centuries,
beginning with the first Arab siege of
Constantinople, which took place between
the years 674 and 678.
When Muslim forces failed again in the
second great Arab siege of
Constantinople 717 to 718, conquering
the ancient Christian capital became
something of an obsession for a
succession of caliphates and sultenates.
However, it was only with the rise of
the Turks, particularly the Ottoman
Turks, that conquering the cities, which
remained one of the best fortified in
the world, became a possibility, not
least in thanks to the conccominant rise
of gunpowder and cannons. By 1400, the
Ottomans had already managed to invade
and conquer a significant portion of the
southern Balkans, thereby isolating and
essentially turning Constantinople into
a Christian island in an Islamic sea.
Enter Sultan Muhammad II, the mortal
enemy of the Christians, to quote from a
contemporary prelate. Note, Mahmed, as
this Sultan is almost always called
today, is simply an English
transliteration of the Turkish
pronunciation of Muhammad. Early
European historians always called him
Muhammad because that's his name. And I
suspect this transliteration was adopted
as a subtle way of distancing this
particular Muhammad from his namesake,
Muhammad the prophet. We shall soon see
why. At any rate, once he became Ottoman
Sultan in 1451, Constantinople sent a
diplomatic embassy to congratulate
Muhammad. The 19-year-old responded by
telling them what they wanted to hear.
He swore by the god of their false
prophet, by the prophet whose name he
bore. A bitter Christian contemporary
later wrote that he was their friend and
would remain for the whole of his life a
friend and ally of the city and its
ruler Constantine the 11th. Although
they believed him, Muhammad was taking
advantage of the basist arts of
dissimulation and deceit. To quote
Edward Gibbon, peace was on his lips
while war was in his heart. Today we are
a little more familiar with this Islamic
phenomenon. What was in Muhammad's heart
soon became apparent. Throughout the
spring of 1453, Constantinople watched
helplessly as Ottoman battalion after
battalion made its way to and surrounded
the city by land and sea. One
contemporary remarked that Muhammad's
army seemed as numberless as grains of
sand spread across the land from shore
to shore. In the end, sources indicate
that about 100,000 fighters and 100
warships came to surround the city.
Incidentally, why did Muhammad II and
his predecessors, the Arabs, attack
Constantinople in the first place? What
made it an enemy of the Turks and before
them the Arabs? The same thing that made
every non-Muslim nation an enemy. It was
non-Muslim and therefore it needed to be
subjugated. That was the sole grievance
that propelled the Turks to besiege it.
As with their Arab counterparts during
the seventh and 8th
centuries, few Western Europeans came to
Constantinople's aid once the siege
began. The Catholic Orthodox schism was
still an issue. In the end, less than
7,000 Christian fighters, 2,000 of whom
were foreigners, made ready to protect
15 mi of walls while only 26 Christian
ships patrolled the harbor. This
against, as seen, 100,000 Muslims and
about 100 warships. Once all his engines
of war were set up, Muhammad commenced
bombardment on April 6th. Although he
tried to go over, through, and under the
walls, he made little headway. Some 6
weeks after he had started bombarding
the city, he was no nearer to his goal.
At his wits end, the Sultan held council
with his senior
officers. Although there was some
discussion of withdrawing, in the end,
Muhammad decided on vomiting forth every
last man he had against the walls in one
final ditch effort. But first, he would
need to inflame his followers. So he
assembled and exhorted the Muslim army.
As it happens in all battles, he began,
"Some of you will die as it is decreed
by fate for each man. Recall you now the
promises of our prophet concerning
fallen warriors in the Quran. The man
who dies in combat shall be transported
bodily to paradise and shall dine with
Muhammad in the presence of women,
handsome boys, and virgins. Still,
Sultan Muhammad was shrewd enough to
know that rewards in the now were always
far preferable to promises in the
hereafter." As she Aksham Sadin had
earlier told him, "You well know that
most of the soldiers have in any case
been converted to Islam by force." The
number of those who are ready to
sacrifice their lives for the love of
Allah is extremely small. On the other
hand, if they glimpse the possibility of
winning booty, they will run towards
certain death. So the Sultan swore that
his warriors would be granted the right
to sack everything, to take everyone,
male or female, and all property or or
treasure which was in the city. and that
under no circumstances would he break
his oath. Again, the Catholic pre-late
who was present wrote, "He asked nothing
for himself except the buildings and
walls of the city. All the rest, the
booty and the captives would be theirs."
"Any Muslim still uninspired by the
boons of the here or hereafter was left
with a final thought. If I see any man
lurking in the tents and not fighting at
the wall, warned the Sultan, he will not
be able to escape a lingering death."
This was a reference to Muhammad's
favorite form of punishment, impalement,
which Vlad the Impaler, Dracula, was
introduced to as a youth when he was a
hostage of this same Muhammad. At any
rate, the Sultan's announcement was
received with great enthusiasm and joy.
And from thousands of throats came waves
of thundering cries of Allah Akbar and
proclamations of the shahada that there
is no god but Allah and Muhammad is the
messenger of Allah. Oh, if you had heard
their voices raised to heaven, wondered
a Christian behind the wall. You would
have been struck dumb with amazement. We
were amazed at such religious fervor and
begged God with copious tears to be well
disposed towards us. All this most
terrible shouting, said another
eyewitness, was heard as far as the
coast of Anatolia, 12 mi away, and we
Christians were very fearful. The
all-out assault was set for May 29th.
Atonement, ablutions, prayers, and
fasting under penalty of death were
ordered for the Ottoman camp. The
previous day, fanatics of all sorts were
set loose to inspire the men to jihad.
Wandering dervishes visited the tents to
instill the desire to martyrdom and the
assurance of spending an immortal youth
amidst the rivers and gardens of
paradise and in the embraces of the
blackeyed virgins, the fabled hurries,
writes historian Roger Crowley. Criers
swept throughout the camp to horn
blasts. And they said, quote, "Children
of Muhammad, be of good heart, for
tomorrow we shall have so many
Christians in our hands that we will
sell them, two slaves for a ducket, and
will have such riches that we will all
be made of gold. And from the beards of
the Greeks, we will make leashes for our
dogs, and their families will be our
slaves. So be of good heart, and be
ready to die cheerfully for the love of
our Muhammad." Past and present
Muhammad, I assume they mean. Finally,
on May 29th, around 2 a.m., Muhammad
unleashed all hell against
Constantinople. To blasting sounds of
trumpets, symbols, and Islamic war
cries, cannon fire lit the horizon as
ball after ball came careening into the
walls of the Christian city. Church
bells and alarms added to the
pandemonium. After the initial wave of
cannon fire, the sultan implemented his
strategy to engage successively and
without halt, one body of fresh troops
after the other. He had told his
generals, "Until harassed and worn out,
the enemy will be unable further to
resist." So on and on, wave after wave,
the hordes came, all desirous of booty
or paradise, or merely to evade
impalement. With ladders and hooks they
fought, clawed and clamped onto the
wall. Who could narrate the voices, the
cries of the wounded, and the
lamentation that arose on both sides?
Recollected a Christian eyewitness. The
shouts and den went beyond the
boundaries of heaven. After 2 hours of
this Armageddon, thousands of the
Ottomans most expendable raiders lay
dead beneath the wall. Having served
their purpose of wearing the defenders
down, Muhammad, now mounted near the
wall and directing traffic with a mace
in his hand, ordered another wave of
fresh Anatolian Turks to clash against
the wall. They built and clawed at top
human pyramids of their own dead and
wounded. All while cannonballs continued
to carine and crash into the wall. But
the vastly outnumbered defenders
persevered. Having the high ground, the
Christians slew countless. One could
only marvel at the brutes conceded one
defender of the wall. Their army was
being annihilated. And yet they dared to
approach again and again.
By 4:00 a.m. non-stop cannon fire had
made several breaches which the Ottomans
elite shock troops the Janiseries that
is abducted Christian boys who were
indoctrinated and trained in jihad
charged even as their former
co-religionist held firm. An eyewitness
account offers a
snapshot. It's a long one. Quote, "The
Christian defenders fought bravely with
lances, axes, pikes, javelins, and other
weapons of offense. It was a
hand-to-hand encounter and they stopped
the attackers and prevented them from
getting inside the palisade. There was
much shouting on both sides. The mingled
sounds of blasphemy, insults, threats,
attackers, defenders, shooters, those
shot at, killers, and dying of those who
in anger and wrath did all sorts of
terrible things. And it was a sight to
see there, a hard fight going on
handtoand with great determination and
for the greatest rewards. Heroes
fighting valiantly. The one party,
Muslims, struggling with all their might
to force back the defenders, get
possession of the wall, enter the city,
and fall upon the children and women and
the treasures. The other party,
Christians, bravely agonizing to drive
them off and guard their possessions,
even if they were not to succeed in
prevailing and in keeping them. A small
detachment of Turks finally entered the
city through a minor doorway, which the
defenders had left open during the
chaos. They quickly planted the Islamic
flag, causing consternation among the
defenders. Playing on their worst fears,
the Sultan cried aloud, "The city is
ours!" and ordered his best janisaries
to charge. One named Hassan, described
as a giant of a beast, slew all before
him and inspired the other Muslims to
press in behind him. When a well- aimed
stone took him down, he continued
swinging his scimitar on one knee until,
riddled and overwhelmed by arrows, he
was welcomed into paradise by the
Huries. By then, continues an
eyewitness, the whole host of the enemy
were on our walls, and our forces were
put to flight. Thousands of invaders
flooded in and slaughtered the
outnumbered defenders. Others were
trampled underfoot and crushed to death
by the press of men, crying, "The city
is lost, but I live," Emperor
Constantine the 11th stripped and flung
off his royal regalia and spurred on his
horse and reached the spot where the
Turks were coming in large numbers.
Writes again an eyewitness. With his
steed he knocked the impious from the
walls and with his drawn sword in his
right hand he killed many opponents
while blood was streaming from his legs
and arms. Inspired by their lord men
shouting better to die rushed into and
were consumed by the oncoming throng.
The emperor continues the eyewitness was
caught up among these fell and rose
again then fell once more never to be
seen again. Thus he died by the gate
with many of his men like any commoner
after having reigned for 3 years and 3
months concludes the chronicler and on
that May 29th 1453 the
226-year-old Roman state died with him
and the saying observed another
contemporary was fulfilled. It started
with Constantine the great who founded
Constantinople or Nova Roma New Rome in
325 and it ended with Constantin the
11th. Even so, by holding out against
Islam for as long as it did eight
centuries, Constantinople did indeed
play an important role in saving the
West. After all, had the Sarissens
captured Constantinople in the 7th
century rather than the 15th, wrote
historian John Julius Norwick. All
Europe and America might be Muslim
today. Incidentally, an actual image of
Constantine the 11th, the only known
portrait made of him when he was alive,
was unearthed earlier this year. It
shows a face that is as noble as its
fate was tragic. Anyway, so much for the
Muslim sack of Constantinople, which
occurred on today's date, May 29th. In
another video, we will look at the well
doumented and mind-boggling atrocities
Muhammad's Muslim minions committed on
taking the city. For these make the
Islamic State's atrocities seem like
child play. And for the record, this
video is entirely based on the long
chapter I dedicated to the fall of
Constantinople in Sword and Scimitar. If
you're interested in getting the
complete story or in sourcing all the
quotes in this video, check it out, all
45 pages of it. Okay, bye for now. Enjoy
the rest of your May 29th if you can.
[Music]